let's talk about the best hit
high-intensity interval training
exercises
for maximum fat burning okay now i'm
going to give you examples of lots of
high-intensity interval training
exercises that you can do and then i'm
going to tell you the number one
exercise that just blows everything else
away but first let me just explain what
hit exercises are
it's a super high intensity
short duration type exercise that
produces some seriously high growth
hormone spike and other benefits and the
cool thing about it is because you're
using this high intensity short duration
exercise
you're not going to be doing a
tremendous amount of it so it's a
quicker workout which takes less time
for those busy people but let's just
kind of like dissect what exercise
really is
you have four
parts
okay you have the duration or time
you have the intensity of the exercise
and then you have the recovery after the
exercise
and then you also have how many times
you do this specific
exercise how long you do it how long do
you rest and then how many repetitions
of that are you going to do
so typically when you're doing um hit or
high-intensity interval training you're
doing it only for like 30 to 60 seconds
maybe a little bit longer maybe a little
bit shorter
and then you're resting between 30
seconds or usually like a minute to five
minutes
and then you're doing this three times
to seven times
and then as far as per week you might do
it i don't know once or twice or three
times per week that's kind of like the
pattern now if we take a look at
why high intensity interval training
works
we want to look at
these variables a little bit deeper
intensity is the
key factor in exercise that stimulates
muscle growth and also stimulates
growth hormone okay now if we have a low
intensity
and high duration a long period of time
of exercise so let's say you're just
jogging down the street over a long
period of time it's not very intense but
you're just jogging for like 45 minutes
you will not stimulate growth hormone
near as strong as compared if you do a
short duration high intensity type
workout now the other key thing about
this is this recovery part too because
if you don't recover from this intensity
you're not going to see the results
nearly as strong as if you did take in
consideration the recovery now recovery
is an individual thing each person has
a different ability to recover and
there's a really good
test that i'm going to recommend that
you do to determine your recovery
as one of the cautions because you last
thing you want to do is over train
yourself and end up hurting yourself
you know you don't want to do this if
you have injuries because it's high
intensity
you also don't want to do it if you have
poor recovery and i'm going to show you
a good test to figure that out and you
don't want to do it if you have heart
problems because doing this intensity
exercise without supervision when you
have a heart problem could be an issue
so this is what you'd want to do you'd
want to first check your resting pulse
rate okay you can get a pulse meter by
checking your pulse on your fingertip uh
you can also just check your pulse here
or here and you're going to count how
many beats per minute okay or you could
count it for 15 seconds and then
multiply it times four now normally an
average pulse rate is about 72. if your
pulse rate is like high like 90 100
higher than that then you need to check
that out because that's not normal and a
resting pulse right if it's low that's
much better but it really depends
because if you don't work out and it's
really really low that could be a heart
problem but if you do exercise and
you're somewhat fit the the pulse rate
should be
like less than 72 it should be like in
the 60s some people they're very fit
even comes down to the 50s or even the
40s and that's a healthy heart all right
so this is what you're gonna do you're
gonna exercise for one minute and you're
gonna do it really intense like about
eighty percent of your maximum intensity
and so just use judgment on this i don't
wanna get too complicated just go really
hard okay for one minute
and then check your pulse rate at the
end of that one minute exercise so let's
say it was
160 okay you got your pulse rate up to
160.
then you're going to rest for one minute
okay then you're going to check your
pulse rate again and let's say it's 150
all right you're going to subtract these
two numbers
this happens to be 10 okay and then you
use this little chart right here if your
pulse rate only comes down
12 beats or less okay that's bad
that means you're at a higher risk of
having a heart problem
now i had this lady come into my office
and we did this test
and her pulse rate got up to 150 okay
and then for some reason i didn't really
check after resting i think we forgot
about her something and she went home
well the next day she came in i checked
her pulse rate again
guess what it was
150
that's really bad
so her pulse rate did not even change
after 24 hours okay that means she has
no recovery and i've only seen that uh
bad situation another time where this
this guy who was in the special forces
uh he was in some
exercise he had to jump from a plane
using a parachute and somehow he landed
in the trees and crushed his back and he
got captured for two weeks and tortured
and somehow he survived that trauma and
before that guess what he did for a
living he was a rodeo clown and so he
just had a series of traumas
well when i checked his recovery there
was absolutely zero recovery and he had
very very high blood pressure and a lot
of problems we did help him eventually
and that just gives you another example
of a poor recovery
now if this top number and body number
come out to be 13 to 20 okay
there's a moderate risk
of a problem so you want to go kind of
light but if you're 20 to 30
okay so if this difference is 20 to 30
you're okay
okay but just it's not perfect but it's
still okay
if it's less than 30
you're in pretty good shape you're great
so
ideally you want that pulse rate to come
all the way down as far as you can
to the resting pulse rate okay
if you can bring it down to your
breasting pulse rate you're in really
really good shape and i remember another
story real quick i have to tell you this
is fascinating this guy he was 80
something years old okay and i noticed
his pulse rate i think it was like 160
came all the way down to his resting
pulse rate and he was in his 80s so i
was very very impressed i was like blown
away that it came down that much and
come to find out
he
won the olympics when he was younger in
water polo and water polo is probably
the toughest sport the most demanding on
your cardiovascular system and your in
your endurance out of any of the sports
and he apparently took first place in
the olympics and he maintained his
physical fitness through this whole
period of time he can hold his breath
easily three minutes underneath the
water so anyway he had really good
recovery all right i just want to show
you one last thing and we'll go right to
the exercises when you um start an
exercise and you raise your pulse rate
you're really stimulating the
sympathetic nervous system okay so this
is all about stimulating the sympathetic
flat or fight mechanism the pulse rate
goes up it adapts to the body changes it
gets blood flow through the body if you
didn't have that your blood pressure
would drop your blood flow and your
brain would drop and you you wouldn't be
able to
climb up the stairs you wouldn't be able
to exercise and then at some point you
stop okay and you're resting
that's this part right here
this is the parasympathetic nervous
system control it's called rest in
digest so the second you stop working
out this system actively comes in there
and starts to push your pulse rate down
it starts to get your body down to this
resting pulse rate and rest state
so it's actually pushing things down
it's a wave pattern
the problem with most people is they
don't really
see this system they don't understand
it's an active system that needs to be
strengthened and the way you strengthen
it is after you work out you let your
your body recover long enough
so when you do this pattern of exercise
to recovery
realize that
this rest period is very very important
to pay attention to and give your body a
chance to fully recover in fact i
recommend that you use your pulse rate
and
add more rest to let your pulse rate
come down to close to the resting state
so instead of doing a pattern of i don't
know 60 seconds to a minute maybe do 60
seconds to four or five minutes rest
especially when you start out that way
you can minimize over training and you
can start to strengthen your recovery
system you strengthen your
parasympathetic nervous system control
all right let me give you some examples
of
hit exercises that are really good
plyometrics there's a sudden burst of
energy
whether you're hopping on a platform or
you're doing some type of explosive
motion okay
i have some old videos of me jumping on
a stump back and forth but that's
plyometrics a really good type of hit
exercise
jumping rope is another good example of
a hit exercise
burpees
another good one
doing kickboxing but with kickboxing you
have to make sure that you rest in
between because sometimes they'll push
you to the point where you there's no
recovery but with kickboxing you can
actually have some explosive movements a
spin bike that's another great workout
where you can actually do a very
short burst of intense exercise using
your legs it's going to get your lungs
and your heart and then you would rest
kettlebell is another one the bulgarian
bag which i'm actually doing right now
which i love it's like a sandbag that
you're doing these different motions and
you're whipping them over your body and
you talk about full body intensity but
you can't do this for more than a minute
and you have to rest
cross fit is pretty intense
the problem that i see with crossfit is
that it's really good if you're younger
but as soon as you get older you better
make sure that you recover a lot longer
because
you need this short burst of high
intensity with good recovery and you
have to make sure that you don't have
injuries
because it can be very traumatic okay
number 10 cross-country skiing now i'm
talking about those machines that you're
simulating cross-country skiing and you
can create some serious intensity in
fact you can burn a tremendous amount of
calories with cross-country skiing
push-ups and sit-ups so you don't really
even need any equipment you can do it
without that using your own body weight
jumping jacks is another one mountain
climber exercise is another one it's
pretty intense and all of these are are
great but the number one high intensity
interval training exercise
is
sprinting
okay
they call it sprinting
interval training okay s-i-t
and a meta-analysis
of over 70 studies they found that
sprinting produced the most fat burning
and the least amount of
time doing it which is very very cool so
when they compared sprint interval
training which is really as a sub type
of high intensity interval training and
they compare these two
there was
39.95 percent higher reduction of fat
overall body fat and using a little more
than 60 percent
less time so you're spending less time
burning more fat if you compare sit
exercises to hit exercises now when they
compared sprint interval training to
mict
which stands for moderate intensity
continuous training which is not quite
as intense and it's longer there was
over a 91 percent high reduction of body
fat using 71
less time so that's really cool so let
me explain a little bit more about how
to do this okay because it's slightly
different you're doing an all-out 100
effort you're going as hard and as fast
as you can using your whole body okay
that's number one
you're not using like 80 of maximum
intensity you're just flat out going as
fast as you can
next thing is you're using very short
duration you're going to find that if
you're going to sprint
you can't go very very far okay because
you're doing this
anaerobically without oxygen in your
cells and you're going to run out of
oxygen really fast but it's a great
great workout not just for fat burning
but overall health i mean if you think
about like a 100 yard dash right these
guys are sprinting 100 yards and a
really good time would be like
12 11 10 seconds i think the world
record was like
nine point something seconds
i mean that is a very very short workout
right well what i'm talking about is
doing a sprint for like 30 seconds up to
60 seconds
now from what i'm talking about with the
sprinting i'm talking about maybe you
start out with 15 second sprints okay
working your way up to
30 second sprints
and maybe eventually up to 60 a second
sprints but
most people won't get up to 60 they'll
stay at 30 second sprints
so that's a very short workout right so
it's a shorter workout
but your rest has to be longer you want
to rest between two and four minutes
with a full rest you don't want to jog
in place you want to sit down let your
pulse rate come all the way down to
normal so this is your workout okay if
you can do sprinting
maybe you find a place where there's a
park with nice soft grass you have your
tennis shoes on and you can sprint you
start out doing your 15 second sprints
okay
and you're gonna do four to six of those
okay maybe you start just with four of
those and then you're going to for
between two and four minutes until you
can check your pulse rate until you're
really calm and then you would do it
again back and forth for about four to
eventually six
sprints in a given workout
and you would only do that
twice a week
that would produce
way more fat burning than any of these
right here i'll put the link down below
of the research all right and lastly
since we're on the topic of fat burning
if you want to speed up your fat burning
okay you need to see this video right
here check this one out next